des élégantes parisienne se livra
l'enseigne du trou madame un club très
fermé à leur nouveau sport favori lapipe
l'histoire n'a retenu que quelques
fumeuses de pipe célèbre mais les émules
de george sand sont loin d'être aussi
rare qu'on pourrait le croire de par le
monde on conçoit donc que cette pipe
d'après-midi a sorti à cet ensemble
tailleur et sa raison d'être au 20e
siècle et que pour le soir on propose
aux élégantes
ce modèle allons tuer
sans doute usage abusif de la pipe à ces
désagréments mais reconnaissons ces
avantage certain sur la cigarette dans
nombre de métiers féminins
la marchande de journaux n'a pas à
craindre une cendre hypocrite et pour
les casseroles sans couvercle la peep
s'impose à la cuisinière consciencieux
[Musique]